EASTERN.
TO AN END, BRET BAIER AND I LIVE
COVERAGE OF THE MUELLER HEARING.
♪ ♪
'S DOING GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
TOMORROW, THE FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER WILL
SPEND THE ENTIRE DAY TESTIFYING
BEFORE CONGRESS.
THAT MEANS THAT FOR YET ANOTHER
24 HOURS, OUR LEADERS WILL
FIXATE ON THE VIRTUALLY
NONEXISTENT THREAT WE SUPPOSEDLY
FACE FROM THE GOVERNMENT OF
RUSSIA.
RUSSIA!
IT'S A SHOW OF COURSE, IT'S A
DIVERSION.
BUT OUR NEWS NETWORKS WILL
DUTIFULLY AMPLIFY IT ANYWAY.
THEY ALWAYS DO.
TURN ON CNN OR MSNBC TOMORROW IT
ANY POINT IN THE DAY AND YOU
WILL HEAR BREATHLESS COVERS OF
DEFENSE THAT CONTAINS PRECISELY
ZERO NEWS.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
WHY ARE THEY SO ANXIOUS TO MAKE
YOU CARE ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S
ENTIRELY POINTLESS?
THAT HAS NO EFFECT ON YOUR LIFE
AND NEVER WILL?
WHY?
MAYBE SO YOU WON'T NOTICE WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY.
THINGS LIKE THIS.
>> ALL MY GOD, THEY CAME OVER
HERE, THEY VIOLATED.
YOU KNOW, THEY VIOLATED THEM.
THEY VIOLATED THEM.
OH, MY GOD, .
Y'ALL GET BACK IN HER CAR.
THEY LAUGHING AT THEM.
>> Tucker: LEVITY WAS REAL.
IT WAS TAPED ON THE GROUNDS WILL
NEIGHBORHOOD OF NEW YORK CITY.
IT SHOWS ON MY PD OFFICERS BEING
ATTACKED WHILE ATTEMPTING TO DO
THEIR JOBS.
REMARKABLY, IT WASN'T THE ONLY
TIME IT HAPPENS.
YESTERDAY'S JUST A FEW MILES
AWAY IN HARLEM, MORE OFFICERS
WERE ATTACKED.
ONE WAS HIT IN THE HEAD WITH A
BUCKET.
WATCH THIS.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE THOSE
VIDEOS?
WELL, WHAT YOU ARE REALLY
WATCHING ON THE TAPE YOU JUST
SAW IS A SOCIETY UNRAVELING.
THE MEN WE HAVE HIRED TO
MAINTAIN ORDER AND KEEP US SAFE
OR ASSAULTED AND HUMILIATED.
THEY COULD DO NOTHING IN
RESPONSE.
THEY COULDN'T ACT BECAUSE THEY
KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE WHAT
KIND OF GOVERNMENT THEY WORK
FOR.
IT'S A GOVERNMENT THAT FAVORS
CRIMINALS OVER SOCIETY ITSELF.
BILL de BLASIO RUNS THE
GOVERNMENT IN NEW YORK CITY,
WATCHING JUST A MONTH AGO, HOW
HE EXPLAINS TO US ON THE
NEW YORK CITY COPS ARE RACIST
MURDERERS.
>> I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
SOMETHING THAT SETS ME APART
FROM ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
RUNNING IN THIS RACE AND THAT IS
FOR THE LAST 21 YEARS, I'VE BEEN
RAISING A BLACK SON IN AMERICA.
AND, I HAVE HAD TO HAVE VERY,
VERY SERIOUS TALKS WITH MY SON
DANTE ABOUT HOW TO PROTECT
HIMSELF ON THE STREETS OF OUR
CITY AND ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY,
INCLUDING HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT HE HAS TO TAKE SPECIAL
CAUTION BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN
TOO MANY TRAGEDIES BETWEEN OUR
YOUNG MEN AND OUR POLICE AS WE
SAW RECENTLY IN INDIANA.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S EASY TO
DISMISS HIM AS A BUFFOON BECAUSE
HE HAS BUT IF YOU ARE A
NEW YORK CITY COP, YOU CAN'T
DISMISS HIM.
THE NYPD WORKS FOR A
BILL de BLASIO.
IMAGINE HEARING YOUR OWN BOSS
DENOUNCE YOU AS A BIGOT ON THE
BASIS OF THE ZERO EVIDENCE.
NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
WHAT EFFECTS WOULD THAT HAVE?
WOULD IT MAKE YOU WANT TO RISK
YOU LIKE TO DO YOUR JOB QUESTION
MIKE WOULD IT CONVINCE YOU JUST
TO GIVE UP?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
YOU JUST SAW THE VIDEO.
WHEN COPS GIVE UP LIKE THAT,
CRIMINALS THRIVE AND THAT MEANS
THAT INNOCENT PEOPLE GET HURT.
SOMETHING SIMILAR IS HAPPENING
IN CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
VIEWED ALMOST EVERY DEMOCRAT IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE SUDDENLY
SOUNDS JUST LIKE
BILL de BLASIO.
>> I HAVE CAN CHALLENGE OUR CAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT TO CHALLENGE
ALL THE WAYS IN WHICH THE
UNIFORM HAS BEEN BURDENED BY
RACISM.
WE'RE GOING TO CRACK DOWN ON
POLICE BRUTALITY AND PRIMARILY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> TRAINING FOR POLICE OFFICERS
ON THEM ELICIT RACIAL BIAS AND
PROCEDURAL JUSTICE BECAUSE TO
DENY IT EXISTS IS TO DENY FOLKS
LIBERTY AND IN MANY CASES, LIFE.
>> HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO LOSE
THE LIVES OF UNARMED BLACK MEN
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AT THE HANDS OF WHITE POLICE
OFFICERS?
THAT IS NOT JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE YOUNG
AND BLACK, YOU ARE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF THE COLOO
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF THE COLOF
YOUR SKIN.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S JUST
THE CASE OF A FEW BAD APPLES.
I BELIEVE IT'S A SYSTEM THAT IS
BROKEN.
>> Tucker: THEY ALL SAY IT
WOULD IT WITH TOTAL CONFIDENCE
LIKE THEY KNOW IT'S TROLL AND
I'VE GOT THE DATA TO PREVENT BUT
IT'S NOT TRUE.
DID ON THE DATA.
IT'S NOT ALIVE.
MOST COPS ARE NOT RACIST AND
ANYONE WHO BOTHERS TO KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE SUBJECT KNOWS
THAT.
IN FACT, JUST THIS WEEK, NEW
STUDY, BY RESEARCHERS AT
MICHIGAN STATE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND FOUND NO SYSTEMIC
RACIAL BIAS AT ALL IN POLICE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT WHETHER COPS
ARE BLACK OR HISPANIC OR WHITE
OR ASIAN OR WHATEVER, THEY HAVE
THE SAME LIKELIHOOD OF USING
FORCE AGAINST A CRIMINAL
SUSPECT.
IN ORDER TO SHOW BIAS, IT TURNS
OUT THE SHOOTING AND CLOSELY
MATCHES THE OVERALL CRIME RATE.
AND IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
POLICE SHOOTINGS, THE CRIMINAL
SUSPECT WAS ARMED OR OTHERWISE
TO AND APPEARED TO POSE A DANGER
TO POLICE.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE BAD
COPS OUT THERE.
OF COURSE.
JUST AS THERE ARE BAD TEACHERS
OUT THERE AND BAD SENATORS AND
AN AWFUL LOT OF BAD LAWYERS BUT
MOST COPS ARE NOT BIGOTS.
IT IS JUST NOT TRUE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF IT.
THE LINING LAW ENFORCEMENT
THOUGH SO THEY DO IT.
BUT THE REST OF US OUGHT TO BE
VERY WORRIED.
IF YOU ARE OVER 40, YOU MAY
REMEMBER THIS USED TO BE A MUCH
MORE DANGEROUS COUNTRY THAN IT
IS TODAY.
HUGE PARTS OF URBAN AMERICA WERE
UNINHABITABLE BECAUSE OF CRIME.
YOU NEVER WONDERED WHY WE BUILT
THOSE SPRAWLING SERVERS
EVERYWHERE?
THAT'S WHY WE DID IT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE AFRAID TO
LIVE IN CITIES.
AND I COULD EASILY HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND IT MAY.
PEOPLE LIKE PEOPLE TO JUDGE --
COOKED GO TO JUDGES RUNNING
AROUND PROMISING TO CUT IT IN
HALF.
MARTYRS, DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY ARE OUT.
CORY BOOKER MEANWHILE IS
PROMISING TO RELEASE A MURDEROUS
DRUG LORD CALLING HIM A
NONVIOLENT OFFENDER.
EVERY DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE,
NOTES SANCTUARY CITIES ARE
EVERYWHERE IN AMERICA.
ALL OF THESE ARE CONNECTED BY A
THREAD.
THEY ARE ALL ATTACKS ON LAW AND
ORDER BUT THERE IS A DEEPER
PROBLEM.
WHAT THEY REALLY ARE OUR ATTACKS
ON SOCIETY ITSELF.
AND THEY ARE HAVING AN EFFECT.
OUR BIGGEST CITIES ARE NOW
FILLED WITH FILTHY HOMELESS
CAMPS.
THE BUBONIC PLAGUE HAS RETURNED
TO LOS ANGELES FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE THE CONQUISTADORS
LEFT.
DRUGS ARE INCREASING IN GREATER
NUMBERS.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE A JOKE.
PEOPLE CAN GET MARRIED, BUY
HOMES, HAVE KIDS, THE TAX
INCREASINGLY CONTROLS WHAT YOU
DO, WHAT YOU SEE, WE ARE ALLOWED
TO THINK ABOUT THESE OR THAT
SOME OF THE REAL PROBLEMS THAT
WE FACE IN THIS COUNTRY.
PROBLEMS THAT CHALLENGE OUR
FUTURE AS A NATION.
THEY ARE NOT SMALL THINGS AND
YET, OUR LEADERS IGNORE THEM
COMPLETELY.
TO THEM, AMERICA HAS JUST TWO
PROBLEMS.
RUSSIA AND ANTIWHITE RACISM.
IT'S DELUSIONAL.